Daniel yes what's phonology probably
address my hair yeah yeah this is what
my head looks like now which I'm seeing
on the screen for the first I don't look
I'm filming Frankenstein at the moment
and I'm playing Igor and this is what
Eagles hair looks like but that's not
your hair is it no it's extensions oh
yeah man look at Mary she's all over
like a rash
grooming you like a monkey she was I
mooned little brother play around back
there
can we change the subject please
I had this extraordinary career and you
know I mentioned the Oscars in the
introduction and things but Harry Potter
weirds me
but that did want to change your life in
a way yeah well yes a lot of very small
people kind of say hello to me and and
that was nice different lot of people
yes but also to where that they'd only
know you for that one thing like you've
never existed before
no I never had and except what one
monkey once said to me he said were you
were you really a cat and I heard myself
say just pull yourself together statics
and things don't you I don't love them
no but don't you like you choose jobs to
avoid them after Voldemort I did I have
much of that as prosthetics on Voldemort
actually to be on something volume on
not so much they a lot of painting and
boy yo yeah very little I tease I
that's your last round you guys shave
the beard all right yeah
there was another moment when you got
him new the Voldemort look was working
when you were on set I knew you met yeah
I passed by the script supervisor has a
little boy he was on set I mean his son
maybe her her son I think it for five
years old
anyway I passed by this little child I
just looked at this boy he is burst into
tears
you can't talk about your career without
mentioning Harry Potter because you were
so rare that I said people you know
they're funny because they actually get
really scared if I was walking down
Hampstead street at something atually
just screamed a load of what you know
really really scared you go and then
their young children who are scared of
me yeah between then Loretta something's
quite useful I take my what I've got a
wand at home so when the when Billy
brings my son he brings kids who I don't
really like I just like water being take
your goods you know take the wand out
and they still do you know a Halloween
presumably trick-or-treating people just
run away from your house screaming it's
amazing at one time we don't have to
dress up blended
bless I ought to just it's like it's
like trying to chop down on like yeah
it's very soft doesn't it thank you
it's real dead human beings hair is it
yours no it's it's it's from I assume a
dead person or person that donated their
hair somebody donated their hair someone
who's had the hair cut off yes it was
found on the floor
did you see Mamma Mia use regular Mamma
Mia did you see that was a dreadful film
I got shot nine times but it was one
time so and I just didn't see the person
coming or I would avoid it
yes most of them in the legs I hit my
hand and hit in the face so like the
fragment portion of it is in my tongue
so it kind of changed when I speak a
little bit like is it still in your
tongue
can you see yeah it's great for oral sex
let me just make a note of that
I'm a better man now babies another good
longer can you see it yeah let's have a
feel 50 I've washed my hands
make sure ol section did you get up in
my mouth hey I better not have a look
come on look see if you boys know I mean
that's good enough said I'm gonna take
the audition we I could feel it
people want a picture of that and you
know you think I'm never gonna meet
Daniel Radcliffe don't worry because I
have you seen this you you like the
Internet
have you seen this thing on reddit I've
been made aware of this I think this
year is this time traveling in a Daniel
Radcliffe time traveler yeah what it is
people post old photograph that's like
everyman you in happen you really do
so people boast old photographs and then
you have to scan them very carefully to
see if you can manage to spot who in the
photograph looks like Daniel Radcliffe
so can you spot Daniel diffractive time
traveler in this picture yeah
the next one the next one's easier
because there are three people can you
see which of the three people this is
Daniel Radcliffe time traveler do
pictures of me take me when I was
younger like that's very very very close
down it's gonna record ever went on who
do you think you are at some point
surely this photograph will come up
now you didn't I'm guessing you don't
sugarcoat things you get stars talking
to me Michael I do sometimes I do
sometimes I remember when I was young I
and I met Laurence Olivier
well that was i I used to collect
autographs at the stage door and he came
out and I remember so distinctly that I
started to cream in my knickers wherever
we thought that story was going
I honestly don't think I've ever been
more uncomfortable
I fell on my face I forgot to thank the
director so I was just like what does it
all mean nothing so to you but on the
show